فهل باتت طريق الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
بردوغان نحو ولايه ثالثه معبده بعد حصوله
على تاييد مرشح الرئاسه المنهزم في الجوله
الاولى سنان اوغان الاكيد ان تاييد اوغان
شكل دفعه مهمه لاردوغان دعم اوغان
لاردوغان لم يمر دون خلق جدل واسع سيما
بعد تداول اخبار عن مساومه اردوغان لاوغان
مقابل منحه منصبا حكوميا في حال فوته
اردوغان لم يتاخر في نفي هذه الاخبار
مشيرا الى انه لم يضع اي شرط مقابل الحصول
على تاييد
اما فيما يتعلق بمطالب اوغانا التي تخص
ملف اللاجئين اوضح اردوغان انه تمت اعاده
450 الف لاجئ الى بلادهم والهدف سيكون
اعاده توطين مليون لاجئ اخرين في شمال
سوريا
على الطرف الاخر وفي اول تعليق الله على
قرار اوغان بدعم رئيس تركيا اردوغان وعدل
المرشح الرئاسي كما الكلج منافسه منافس
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه وعد بانقاذ
تركيا من الارهاب واللاجئين في حال فوزه
حسب تعبيره نشر في تدوينه على تويتر قال
فيها انه من الواضح من الذي يؤيد بيع هذا
الوطن الجميل واضف بالقول انه قادم لانقاذ
هذا البلد من الارهاب واللاجئين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات